hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
today from Conan O'Brien one of my
heroes for sure growing up in a junior
high I would stay up late at night watch
this guy called it my cone zone medicate
shown love it he has a podcast guy that
is so damn good I love that podcast be a
dream to go on it John yeah you should
be Conan's friend I'd love to be Conan's
friend do you be a great friend
I'd be shy and I'd be sexually abusive
to him so one of our top rewards here's
on patreon is whatever video you're
requesting must definitely do and put up
on the youtubes and today comes from
alumni Beauty from Texas so yeah this
one is Conan and Billy Eichner joined
grinder a I don't know how this one
slipped by me this sounds like fun
okay I saw the tinder one with dave
Franco so just to clarify you know
nothing about tinder but you definitely
know about the existence of Grindr I
know Brian Cole his remotes are my
favorite thing he does dude man you're
failing as you're going as a grown and
friend it seemed like a billion other
overs remotes some of his stuff got put
on Netflix for you saying yeah no like
if I already calls him it's like when he
goes to like a different country
oh yeah conan abroad or whatever yeah
yeah something like that where he goes
to a different country instead of on
youtube they divided into like you know
five to ten minute segments they put it
on it's like kind of a documentary
episode it's much harder for that yeah
anyhow let's get to it
yep
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
responses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
looks like are you wanna
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we know I
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
over there but did make a new friend in
a supermarket parking lot
[Applause]
guy wonder what the post conversation
was with that guy yeah one and the
conversation that led up to them meeting
because you know that they had to figure
some legal stuff you think so
well I don't know if he would've
happened before or after cuz you know
when they're in the office they showed
his pictures so obviously he had to sign
off on this and stuff I would be very
curious about a bit of post sign-off
like after they do everything
I may be that's the thing is if he just
agreed if he just believed it and agreed
to end up that is kind of impressive
yeah like if that was like really by
chance then he just happened to reply
and realized who it was and then decided
to meet up then yeah you know the funny
thing is the I I recently searched for
an Applebees in that area and there is
not one for 12 months Dan that lucky guy
why didn't I go on Grindr a year ago or
two two years ago
you gotta get Grindr in case he revives
this bit I really should gotta be on
every app in case Conan's there I got a
do with Logan Paul said and I got a go
gay temporarily attempt to go gay for
just one more one and then swing and I
go back that went over well for Logan
Paul oh yeah people love that because
being gay is a choice it's a choice and
I get that now and I should have chosen
like Logan Paul yeah to have gone gay be
trendy that's what this is about
dammit trendiness yeah I love Conan
though man you do his level of improv is
so impressive oh yeah that ability to
believe any scenario or just act as if
okay you get this slight tingle of is he
really actually kind of into this you
know in a different way I'm not saying
here we going oh Conan's actually hook
up with someone in cheat on his wife or
the guy you get that vibe though just
how much joy he has from Scoobies yeah
what he and Billy Eichner make a great
pair for this like their chemistry
together in their Bay
- back and forth with a lot of fun -
it's really I loved Conan so much
because I've listened to a lot of also
you know it's like college speeches he's
gonna colleges before this is easily the
most pathetic school motto I have ever
heard this is like hour-long interviews
I think subconsciously I was inspired
when I was younger like I always
referenced in junior high was when I
discovered Late Night with Conan O'Brien
and when I was younger I think that's
where I really learned self-deprecating
humor oh yeah he's the master of it and
then listening to interviews of him it's
actually pretty inspiring and also
listening to his podcast we're like sure
he has insecurities he's
self-deprecating also a confident guy
he's also a wise observant human being
he makes one of his like dangly
qualities and his pale skin in his Lane
we're hair this is structurally very
sound and what I love about that is he
took all the things that are weird about
him he took insecurities embrace them
and now he's a massively successful dude
wearing to me that's really inspiring to
embrace her insecurities and play on
them and to become the success you are
now and it shows even here you know when
he's like lifting up his shirt and
making fun of his pale skin or when he
pretends to be cocky or egotistical but
you just know that's not really a man
it's a caricature of that attitude yeah
it's always clear that coming from him
it doesn't mean but yeah you know that
ability to distinguish I have an
audience be able to distinguish that
where you go that's really not him
because there are some people who played
at but then people walk away going guys
probably freaking [ __ ] he's cocky you
don't get that with Conan ever you know
I certainly don't know I know I could've
had sex with Conan I would have been
like yeah let's put on the band yeah you
got condoms sure I would have yes and
like a mofo oh yeah
now would be a great story to tell your
kids someday you know children I almost
didn't marry your mom but I did get a
divorce
because I had sex with Conan and now I
want to marry in Rob
[Laughter]
spoilers for Breaking Bad yeah all right
well hey Lynnae that rhymes hey it
rhymes
Lynnae my beautiful dear I hope you had
a Merry Christmas a Happy New Year and
that you set yourself some awesome goals
I know you're a woman but you are so
beautiful that have you joined Grindr
u-turn so many gay men straight because
like logan paul said it's a choice yeah
you know flip right back you know we
just did we just got a lot of logan paul
fanatics to go he never said who was a
choice defend him I hope personally that
the next time you send us a video it's a
crossover of wrestling and Conan cuz
you've given us a lot of wrestling so
far and that's been eye-opening and now
with this and the grinder aspect I feel
like we could bring these all together
well wrestling is in some ways a little
gay it's a little homoerotic yeah yeah
and a really strong fierce win in a
bearish kind of way yeah are there any
like wrestling otters or twinks and
stuff why would otters wrestle each
other you know
territory that's stupid I don't know
what I'm calling stupid your thing about
otters wrestling or my joke about otters
are not home phones hominin twitch are
the ones that are the same word but they
mean different you cause one of them
like Romo phones and homonyms like one
of them sounds alike but they're spelled
different and one of them they're like
spelled it's like the same spelling but
different me I don't know somebody who's
an English major comment below
Lynnae if you know the English language
better than me enlighten us
alright well Lynnae I hope you have a
good day make sure that's a night you go
ahead and pray go to your parents and
the words I love you Yuma
say and wish away all the things that
lead to a bad day and to all the haters
in your life say nay and know that it's
okay that in life sometimes you can be a
little cray subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Bell
check us out on patreon we got weekly
Q&A s TV show reaction watch alongs
music video coverage if you like
sketches that we do patrons allowed us
to do 5 last year yeah we'd already did
one this year go support us over there
plus you get perks and goodies see